[Music]
morning everyone we start today with
concerns over Pension funds following a
warning from the bank of England
Governor Andrew Bailey where he ruled
out extending the help they've been
giving that news caused the pound to
plunge in overnight trading on Asian
markets it dipped against the dollar to
one dollar and nine cents this morning
though we're hearing one report that the
bank of England has been privately
briefing that it will continue with its
interventions Beyond Friday all that is
the latest growth figures are revealed
let's get more should we pull standing
by for us uh Paul what's the latest good
morning to you
yeah good morning okay the latest is bad
news for the economy in August the
latest GDP figure that's the size of the
economy the growth in the economy well
it contracted the economy got smaller
fell by uh minus 0.3 in August now that
tallies with the predictions we've had
from the bank of England its forecasters
that the UK will be entering a recession
in this quarter that is starting now in
October but already the figures for
August the end of summer showing a
contraction there was a bank holiday in
that month which may have contributed uh
to slightly less economic activity but
this is a sign of the headwinds in which
this new government is operating of
course business is already facing
perhaps contraction in the economy know
they're going to face much higher
borrowing costs as a consequences of the
market turmoil in the last few weeks
back in August of course they were
looking at energy bills and not knowing
quite what the government was going to
do about it well they known that now
that the challenge here for businesses
is to try try and keep going and we know
the labor market is is not keeping up
there are more vacancies we discovered
yesterday in the economy than there are
unemployed people to do them a record
number of people off six so a great deal
of pressure on the economy and the
challenge for a government which wants
to be measured by growth is that we get
a measure every month and today the
measure is the economy is Contracting
thanks very much indeed Paul thanks uh
Jacob reesenborg Secretary of State for
business is with us this morning quick
thought on that to start with please
um figures that are released immediately
are very often revised so the previous
quarters figure showed a contraction was
then advised to show economic growth so
be very careful about how you interpret
figures immediately after their release
okay so we shouldn't take too much
notice of that it's a small amount of a
very large economy but these figures are
notorious for being revised afterwards
are our Pension funds at risk uh no our
Pension funds aren't at risk
um some Pension funds have taken some
high risk Investments
um Andrew
um said that um
in three days time Friday
um Pension funds uh that he has been
trying to support by the bank of England
he will withdraw the emergency help for
that
How concerned are you by by that
language
um the question is not many failed
really but first of all there's the
issue of the relatively high risk
Investments that some Pension funds have
made that they were gearing on their
Guild Holdings and the problem with
gearing is that when values change if
they change sharply which has been a
phenomenon with guilds because of the
change in interest rates so the
underlying base rate has gone up
significantly in this country and
globally and now if you've seen long
rates move out and that's been happening
here as elsewhere that's had an effect
on Pension funds there's also also
valuation issue with long-term guilds
many Pension funds will be holding them
for their full duration we'll be
expecting to get them redeemed at the
end of 30 years but maybe on an
obligation to mark them to Market if
they're marking them to Market they may
find that they have actually a false
valuation on investment that's intended
to be held to maturity I'm sure that my
uh viewers my audience got most all of
that but the bottom line is that Andrew
Bailey thought it was in concerning
enough to offer emergency help that will
be withdrawn he says on Friday I'm
saying to you how concerned should we be
that the governor of the bank of England
and these very important job has said
come Friday they're on the road
well the bank of England is obviously
operationally independent and that's
quite right and the governor will make
decisions in accordance with the markets
but the bank of England does have a
responsibility and has had a
responsibility for a very long time to
ensure the orderly functioning of
markets and therefore it intervenes from
time to time when there are unexpected
events
when does it become the government's
problem
well the government of the bank of
England work very closely together
within the confines of the independence
of the bank of England
that the bank of England is quite
rightly operationally independent and
you will remember all the arguments over
this about why it was better to have an
independent interest rates better
um but nonetheless economic decision
making involves both the bank of England
and the government so the two the two
work together in the confines of
independence of the bank you don't think
it's a problem with them with the
pensions and the bank of England does no
the bank of England has made its
position clear that it's been helping
because of a specific problem what I was
answering was whether there is a
systemic problem in Pension funds which
there doesn't seem to be are there
problems with some Pension funds that
have taken risky Investments which the
bank of England is helping with yes
these are two separate questions should
they continue with their help post
Friday I shouldn't intervene in matters
where the banking operates into
independently okay well I'm reading the
Ft this morning which is suggesting that
privately the bank of England is saying
that it will support Beyond Friday
um is that the governor potentially
stoking up anxiety unnecessarily you
must interview the government be quiet
look I'm a government Minister the bank
of England is independent I think the
bank of England Independence is
fundamental to the stability of the UK
economy and I think government ministers
therefore have no business
um wading in on what the bank of England
is is doing the banking the car's
Independence yeah I understand that but
if the bank of England is saying the
Andrew Bailey is saying one thing in
public and one thing in private and that
is impacting the markets that's
impacting our economy which is impacting
the government you must interview Mr
Bailey what's your view no I'm not going
to criticize the bank of England uh or
the governor that it not for me to
speculate on what the bank of England is
doing it isn't yes of course I've Got
Confidence in the government banking
it is so important that we have an
independent bank of England with a
respected Governor Andrew Bailey is a
respected governor and the bank of
England's Independence is operating as
it should he must make the decisions in
relation to Market support and for
ministers to interfere would be
undermining the Independence Bank of
England doesn't have much confidence in
the government it says the situation
with the economy is Way Beyond anything
the bank has stress tested for well the
bank of England stress test should be
there to ensure the bank of England is
ready for whatever happens within the
economy but you shouldn't be surprised
by some of the moves markets do move
quickly and we have had the lowest level
of interest rates in history not just in
decades not just since
1970 or any of those figures but in the
whole of our economic history we have
had consistently the lowest rates now
that was always going to change at some
time sooner and when it changes it
changes on the long rate more than it
does on the short rate usually for
obvious reasons well
interest rates are set independently by
the bank of England but they're also set
by the markets so the markets determine
when long rates move rather than it
being set by the bank opinion you're a
very successful businessman you know a
lot about the markets as you've already
Illustrated do you think interest rates
should have come out sooner again the
bank of England is independent so I'm
going to keep my private views private
um
it certainly had an impact on people's
mortgages hasn't it um what impact has
it had on your mortgage but I've never
thought that my personal financial
circumstances we could discuss yours as
well
mortgage has gone up what about yours
mortgage rates have gone up for
everybody who has a mortgage and I have
a mortgage but my personal financial
circumstances I don't think that
um ones to draw generals
and I've answered and we've both had
mortgages that have gone up and so as
your mortgage gone up now
any floating rate mortgages have gone up
has yours Yes mine has gone up okay
um do you think
benefits should go up in line with
inflation we haven't yet had the
inflation figure on which benefits will
be said so that is something that will
be decided once the figure is available
well well we know that you can predict
these things very successfully
um we're also have the help of many
other very clever people who are saying
that inflation would go up about 10 well
you you say wages will go up about 5.2
something like that you say You can
predict these things actually most
predictions most economic forecasts uh
turn out to be inaccurate rather than
spot on so one's got to be careful about
forecast as I was saying earlier with
the GDP figure inflation is going to get
more than wages isn't it lots of figures
that come out get revised later but I
think the broad Point you're making that
inflation will rise more than wages at
this year is accurate and to that end
should benefits go up in line with
inflation there's a process for making
this decision this decision will be made
once the figures come out a stature
instrument has to be laid in November
um to put through the increase that will
be done in the normal away this is
completely routine governmental decision
making its decision made by this extra
safe working pensions that will be made
in the normal way yeah but what's your
opinion
my opinion is government policy I'm not
sitting here as a commentator for a
journal or a backbend Champion I'm
certainly as a member of the government
where there is a decision-making process
the discussions on how things should be
managed are ones that need to take place
in private before a government policy is
announced for which we are then
accountable to Parliament I think to
discuss I think this and he thinks that
and she thinks the other is not a good
way of making government policy no but
surely given the situation that many
people are finding themselves in at the
moment and relying on benefits they need
to be reassured that they will get
benefits increased in line with
inflation well quite a number of
benefits will increase in line with
inflation by law anyway so there's a
subset of benefits where a decision will
be made and the triple lock for
pensioners will remain
in
full state that that will be applied
I spoke to the Deputy Prime Minister
yesterday she said that the economy is
in a good state do you think it is
well I think the economy has some good
points and some areas of difficulty so
you were reporting that the employment
Market remains very strong with
vacancies being lower than the
sorry vacancies being higher than the a
number of people unemployed but there is
a problem with inflation and the
difficulty with inflation is that to
deal with inflation monetary policy has
to tighten and tightening monetary
policy leads to higher mortgages and
higher rates of interest for businesses
and that is never easy it would be wrong
with me to pretend that that is easy so
it's not in a good State there are bits
of it that are in the good state so as I
said employment which is fundamental to
people because employment is the Far and
Away best route out of poverty is in a
very strong state but inflation is not
and that is creating problems yeah okay
um but we go back to what Andrew Bailey
was saying and he says the economy is
Way Beyond anything the bank has Tres
tested for so you know he doesn't think
it's in a particularly good state does
he well he's responsible for monetary
policy and the bank has been putting
interest rates up
um as a consequence of of inflation the
bank of England stress tests are matters
for the bank of England
prime minister as well yesterday about
proposed change to the affordable houses
Target she wasn't aware that there was a
proposed change are you aware of it
um I'm aware that there is a discussion
but I'm not aware of the decision having
been made should we look at potentially
not having as many affordable houses for
people to live in I I think it misses
the dynamism of the market that what
matters is the total housing stock
because people move and therefore you
increase the total that's right but by
increasing the total housing stock you
find that houses at other parts of the
market become affordable and therefore
you create a dynamic system I think the
idea that there are houses that are
affordable and houses that are
unaffordable it's not necessarily the
right way of looking at it you've got to
say affordable for whom and under what
circumstances and then this question not
affordable housing but social housing
and what provision are you making there
so I I think there's a two great a
tendency to look at the housing market
as if it's static when it's Dynamic and
that leads to potentially discussing
issues that don't fundamentally change
where people live which is what really
matters I suppose people who are not
earning a particularly High salaries
like nurses would be looking for their
first starter home and affordable
housing to them would be very different
to potentially affordable housing for me
yesterday to raise coffee so there's no
more money to pay nurses a pay increase
and as a result they are not as a result
of what she said but they want more
money and they're going to go on strike
for the first time in more than 100
years
um the pay round this year has already
started being difficult and we're aware
of that that's an obvious concomitant of
inflation that when inflation rise is
then people understandably ask for
higher wages but those are not
necessarily affordable and the issue
here is how do you deal with the
inflationary problem that is mainly the
monetary policy of the bank of England
but that if you raise wages fully in
line with inflation you get into the
issue of wage push inflation and
continue the inflation maybe or may well
be the case and I'm sure it is but you
know if you can't afford to feed your
kids you want more money don't you
ultimately the taxpayer has limited
resources and we have to live within our
means so how much is available for
public services depends on economic
growth which by the government's policy
is pushing for economic growth and
actually the IMF yesterday predicted
that following the fiscal statement
there would be more great this next year
than it had previously forecast if
there's more growth then there's more
tax revenues then there's more money for
everybody involved
those that just two years ago we were
studying our doorsteps clapping for well
the the wage around this year as part of
a negotiation that negotiation will
continue but the taxpayer has limited
money everything that is done by
government has to be funded by taxpayers
either this year or in future if it's
done through borrowing there is not an
unlimited amount of money and
governments always have to work within
that
what should we do about the coronation
how much should we spend on the
Carnation next year
well I don't have a specific figure for
how much
um we don't have coronations very often
uh I think the key to the coronation
actually is that it's a religious
ceremony it is effectively a Sacrament
the last anointed Monarch uh in Europe
um other arguably than the pope with a
ceremony that dates back to Anglo-Saxon
times
I I think it was
um uh Dunstan Saint Dunstan of
Glastonbury who really devised the
coronation
um no because the costings are entirely
different that comes from the public
person what one is a small one-off
amount in the context of government
expenditure
pay rates are billions of pounds
nobody's talking about a coronation that
will cost billions of Parts how much
should it cost to put a precise figure
on it uh is not not for me to do if it
was to be comparable with the pre
previous one it would be something like
46 million quid that's what it equates
to now from 1953 costs well it depends
how you account for it
um uh I hope we see
um a coronation that is sufficiently
dignified for our Sovereign this is a
one-off course the last one
um was for coronation for a reign of 70
years so this is not something that
happens often it needs to be done
properly and it's completely irrelevant
to pay rates because 46 million pounds
would not buy you an increase in pay for
people employed in the public service of
any amount at all as you know
thank you very much yes thank you very
much indeed let's have a quick look at
what's happening as far as the
newspapers are concerned this morning
here we go and let's start with the
financial times should we
here we go that's the Ft for you the
bank of England's guilt buying operation
which they say was to prevent fire sales
by Pension funds uh the telegraph
meanwhile focuses on the falling value
of the pound in response to the bank uh
pulling the plug on their guilt buying
program
the eye reports on the government's
plans to cap the profits of renewable
and nuclear energy generators in a bid
it says to silence the rebels
the guardian calls the proposed cap a
windfall tax and label it another U-turn
from Liz Tross
the express leads with details of King
Charles slimmed down coronation the
paper says the decision was made to
reflect the cost of living crisis
gripping the country
still to come on the program for you
this morning we'll have the very latest
on the NHS we'll hear about the British
Medical Association worries that Medics
are leaving the NHS when I talk to Dr
shanu Data the deputy chair of the BNI
Consultants committee
we'll hear from the photographer of this
picture and nambia who will join me
later this hour to talk about winning
the behavior mammals category of the
wildlife photographer of the Year award
apparently there is there you go there's
a snow leopard there they're very well
camouflaged and next hour I'll be
talking to Lisa nandi Shadow Secretary
of State for leveling up housing and
communities
[Music]
I just got reaction from the chancellor
of the exchequer on those latest GDP
statistics countries around the world
are facing challenges right now
particularly as a result of high energy
prices driven by Putin's barbaric action
in Ukraine that is why this government
acted quickly to put in place a
comprehensive plan to protect families
and businesses from soaring energy bills
this winter our growth plan will address
the challenges that we face with
ambitious supply side reforms and tax
cuts which will grow our economy create
more well-paid skill jobs and in turn
raise living standards for everyone
almost as if he planned that before we
got the figures no still to come NATO's
defense ministers are meeting this
morning in Brussels to discuss ways to
support Ukraine after increased Russian
missile strikes in the capital Kiev and
12 other cities this week the US
President Joe Biden said late last night
that he doesn't think his Russian
counterpart will be using a tactical
nuclear weapon in the war on Ukraine
I think he is a rational actor who's
miscalculated significantly
I think he thought you may recall I
pointed out that they were going to
invade that all those hundred thousand
or more troops there and gnome believed
that he was going to invade Ukraine he
listened to what he says if you listen
to the speech he made after when that
decision was being made he talked about
the whole idea of he was needed to be
the leader of Russia that United all his
objectives or not I think he thought
Jake I think he thought he's going to be
welcome with open arms
from Brussels uh Deborah standing by for
is now our security and defense editor
of course we was with us in the studio
yesterday hot footed it to Europe
straight after uh bring us up to date if
you would please Deborah good morning
good morning so here today at the NATO
headquarters which is just behind me
you're going to have defense ministers
from the 13 NATO countries meeting and
also members of a us-led grouping that
have gathered since Russia's war in
Ukraine began that they gather as a as a
kind of forum to agree new weapons to
give to Ukraine the Ukrainian President
yesterday
um speaking to G7 leaders
urged for more weapons to help him
protect his skies and there have been
devastating missile strikes by Russia
against Ukrainian cities and the first
major barrage was on Monday a real
escalation it seems to have been
Russia's response to this explosion on
the 8th of October on a bridge
connecting the Crimean Peninsula that
was illegally annexed by Russia back in
2014 with the Russian Mainland and I can
bring you some new new information
that's just emerged from the FSB Russian
Security Service about that attack
they're accusing the main intelligence
directorate of Ukraine's defense
Ministry of being behind the attack
they've released some details about what
they say as their investigation into the
explosion on that bridge saying that it
was in a on a truck bomb accusing a
number of individuals of having been
involved and they said that five Russian
Nationals and three Ukrainian citizens
and an Armenian have been arrested as
part of their investigation Ukraine has
not admitted responsibility for that
explosion
okay for now Deborah thank you very much
thank you
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you know MPS have urged
all women aged 45 over 45
um be invited for an NHS health check so
doctors can talk to them about the
menopause they all party parliamentary
group or menopause has said that far
more needs to be done to help women and
offer advice including making hormone
replacement therapy prescriptions free
on the NHS and improving training for
Medics on symptoms
riot police have fired into residential
neighborhoods in San andaj the capital
of Iran's Kurdistan Province as Amnesty
International and the White House's
National Security advisor criticized the
violence targeting demonstrators angered
by the death of Masa amini meanwhile Oil
Workers joined the protests for the
first time linking an industry key
Iran's theocracy to the unrest
Netflix has signed up to the TV ratings
agency Bob meaning its audiences will
now be measured externally from November
viewing figures for this the streaming
giant will be reported by the
organization which complies compiles
rather audience measurement and TV
ratings in the UK
also this morning one of the last
surviving stars of Hollywood's Golden
Age Angela Lansbury has died at the age
of 96. whether you remember her Murder
She Wrote bed knobs and Broomsticks or
as the maternal teapot in Disney's
Beauty and the Beast hers was a career
that spanned Generations born in 1925 in
Regents Park the british-born actor
found Fame after fleeing the London
Blitz to the U.S Skies Matthew Thompson
looks back now on her life and career
it was one of the most successful shows
in television history and yet Murder She
Wrote was just one of many successes in
Angela Lansbury's 70-year career
born in London in 1925 she find early
Fame as one of the stars of Hollywood's
golden age
Awards and nominations flooded in and
never really stopped she became one of
the most decorated stage actors in
history with five Tony Awards Taylor's
oldest time
[Music]
can be roles in Disney Classics like
Beauty and the Beast endeared her to a
younger generation when I'm in a
supermarket or something a kid will say
to her mother
that's Mrs Potts Taylor's oldest time
song as old as rhyme
and the bee it will be a death mourned
in Hollywood Broadway the West End and
Beyond as a true legend takes her final
Buy
good night love
[Applause]
Angela Lansbury who has died at the age
of 96 floods of tributes for her have
come in overnight including this tweet
from the actress Viola Davis who said
you have influenced generations of
actors to Aspire to Excellence
thought you would live forever what an
absolutely beautiful Legacy you've left
you have influenced generations of
actors to Aspire to Excellence rest well
may flights of angels
West End Legend Elaine page shared this
photo of the pair calling Angela one of
the last golden age of Hollywood stars
and a Broadway and West End Icon
so upset to hear that news that the
legendary Dame Andrew Lansbury has died
one of the last golden age of Hollywood
stars
the crowning of King Charles and the
queen consort Queen Camilla will take
place on the 6th of May Buckingham
Palace says that the ceremony will be
rooted in long-standing Traditions but
also reflect the Monarch's role today
and looks towards the Future Let's uh
get more should we uh taking you to
Westminster Abbey now and Laura is
joining us um hey Laura good morning to
you hearing from Jacob Reese smog a
short time ago he said we should spend
as much as it takes to celebrate the
coronation
lots of questions about that and
there'll be lots of thoughts about that
in the planning process what we do now
is obviously the date and the venue is
always going to be Westminster Abbey
coronations have been held here for 900
years and we know a little bit I think
about what it might look like certainly
I think we can expect a more modest
definitely a more diverse and probably a
shorter ceremony than previous is the
palace though making it clear there will
be tradition there will be pageantry but
that it will also look toward the future
and in terms of what that means well I
don't think it'll resemble the Queen's
coronation here back in June 1953 which
saw 8 000 people packed into the Abbey
for a service that lasted three hours
however there will be as we know now
some core elements of that service the
king will be Anointed with holy oil
he'll be breath blessed he'll be
consecrated he'll have the crown of king
Edward placed on his head the queen
consort will also be anointed in she too
will be crowned then but don't forget
the King was just four years old when he
came to the Abbey to watch his mother's
coronation and I think the challenge for
him now will be how to make this
centuries-old ceremony feel relevant to
Modern Multicultural Britain a Britain
that is of course in the grips of a cost
of living crisis and lots of questions
of course about the bank holiday that's
a decision for the government but
certainly I think the cost of living
crisis will be very much in their minds
and they look about whether or not
there'll be an extra bank holiday for
the event
welcome back with the bank of England
saying it will seemingly not extend its
emergency support package earlier in the
program I spoke to Jacob Reese smog the
Secretary of State for business energy
and Industrial strategy who told me we
don't need to worry about our pensions
being affected by the economic
difficulties
no our Pension funds aren't at risk
um some Pension funds have taken some
high-risk Investments what impact has it
had on your mortgage but I've never
thought that my personal financial
circumstances we could discuss yours as
well
what about yours um mortgage rates have
gone up for everybody who has a mortgage
and I have a mortgage but my personal
financial circumstances I don't think
that
um ones to Georgia I did and I told you
and I've answered and we've both had
mortgages that have gone up and so as
your mortgage gone up no
any floating rate mortgages have gone up
has yours Yes mine has gone up
um Tamara is here with us this morning
good morning and morning thoughts
morning so Jacob B smog is saying
pensions are not at risk don't worry if
you've got a pension fund this is in
response to Andrew Bailey the governor
of the bank of England uh saying
yesterday in Washington in really blunt
terms the bank of England's intervention
in the bond market is coming to an end
this Friday it won't be extended and
saying to investors you've got to get
this done basically saying the ball is
now in the government's Court to to
restore confidence to the market what
does the government need to do well we
know that the chancellor has got this
statement at the end of October on
Halloween to try and balance the books
and show how the government is going to
get debt falling that means really
really difficult decisions on spending
Jacob Reese mogg wouldn't comment there
on whether he thought for example
benefits should be raised by the level
of inflation if the government don't do
that they could save a few billion
pounds we we know today that the
government has announced an intervention
in the renewable energy Market which is
quite tortuously explained in their
press release but basically most people
are saying it amounts to a windfall tax
essentially on green energy which has
been produced at a lower rate than gas
and therefore they have had a bit of a
windfall over the last few months so
that will make a few billion pounds but
that doesn't mean that difficult
decisions in relation to the public
sector won't have to be taken we know
the government will have to find 60
billion pounds according to the
institute for fiscal studies and where
the acts will fall is going to be the
subject of heated debate in government
and of course discussed on the Tory back
benches as well okay for now tomorrow
thank you
back now to the escalating conflict in
Ukraine joined by Ukrainian MP Lisa
yasko hello to you msiasco thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
you are presently in uh Strasbourg
aren't you in France tell us why
good morning well today and this week
there is a parliamentary session of the
Council of Europe when we are going to
vote for the resolution on the Russian
consequences in Ukraine and that
atrocities that Russia is currently
committing in Ukraine so we're working
very hard to make everything possible
that as many countries as possible
recognize Russia as terrorist State and
that we create a real humanitarian
solutions that will protect the human
rights and will make sure that we have
the exchange of the war prisoners
release of political prisoners there is
a lot to be done this week here in
Strasbourg who's listening are are
people open to what you're saying
definitely uh but uh you know the world
used to be very different before this
war and sometimes we lack mechanisms how
how can we do it because yes there are
different monitoring missions there are
resolutions but you know when we vote
for them in the end Russia doesn't care
which means that in the end it's all
about the military support and inventing
completely new uh tools of providing
security to the world order right now
this is what we are doing this is what
is the role of Ukrainian delegation
right now because we know it uh better
than anyone what does it mean to live
with the War and what exactly should be
done to make sure that other countries
also don't get into this terrible
aggression from Russia
our spy Chief here in the UK yesterday
made a speech and said that he we would
know before there was any uh major
concern about the use of nuclear weapons
does that offer you comfort
well
um no I don't think it can offer me a
comfort because
um the threat of nuclear war is very
very high we understand that Putin
doesn't have any logic anymore it's not
possible to justify Putin anymore we
understand that he is in his final
battle of his life where he wants to
prove to all the world that he can do
whatever he wants including taking lands
killing thousands of people destroying
infrastructure and we are
we understand that nuclear uh threat and
strike is is very possible but it's not
going to change a lot on on the scene of
Ukraine of course it's a disastrous it's
a catastrophic
for me it's a big tragedy to see
thousands of people being killed uh
wounded destroyed lives
but it's not going to change the will of
Ukrainian people to restore Justice and
to restore our territorial sovereignty
we know that um Your Leader president
zielinski spoke to the G7 leaders
Yesterday by video link
um what do you think he took out of that
do you think he is getting or that
you're all getting the support that you
so desperately need from the wide world
well I'm sure that every speech of the
landscape is very much needed right now
because it absolutely reflects the needs
and and and the mood and the situation
inside Ukraine I know that sometimes
some Western countries they are just far
and they don't feel the urgency which is
in incredibly frustrating for us because
you know we don't have time for
discussions we are screaming we're
trying to to to do everything possible
to defend uh with our weapon our people
every second and you know having this
kind of discussions that last long
for us of course it's not something
that's that's that is bring brings us
lots of happiness but of course I'm very
happy that there is a connection and a
communication bilateral and with the G7
with the different formats uh on a daily
basis even often this is
this is very important yeah this is very
important okay uh we must let you get
back inside and carry on with your work
thank you very much indeed for joining
us Ms Jessica thank you
thank you thank you thank you the family
of mural Makai the murdered wife of
Robert modoc's Deputy are urging police
to launch a new search for her remains
on a remote beach after the discovery of
a long-lost confession by hercula
according to a letter hidden among the
old Court files Arthur Hassan told his
solicitor he buried her body at jaywick
Sands near clacton in Essex it's
believed
uh the information was never followed up
let's get more should we because uh
Martin's Landing by for his Martin what
more do we know about this story
it's the latest twist in a very long and
tragic Saga um but it shows that the
family of Muriel Makai still has hope
that they will be able at some stage to
find her her remains after after all
these years
um they think that this might be the
most positive and hopeful clue so far
is this the last resting place of kidnap
victim Muriel Makai remote jaywick sands
on the Essex Coast
53 years ago Mrs Mackay was held for
ransom by Two Brothers they were later
jailed for her Murder She was never seen
again
it's now emerged that one of the
brothers Arthur Hussein claimed he
buried her on jaywick sands his
solicitor revealed the Killer's
confession in a letter to the appeal
court in 1972. he said he told local
police
but author Simon farker who discovered
the letter hidden in legal documents
doubts anyone followed up the
information
as far as I can tell no police officer
was ever given this information there
was no visit to see Arthur in prison
either by the police or by that
solicitor this is the only piece of
paper amongst thousands of pieces of
paper which actually name
a possible burial placement Mrs Mackay
was the wife of newspaper executive Alec
Makai she was abducted from their London
home just after Christmas in 1969 her
kidnappers mistook her for Anna the then
wife of Rupert Murdoch Mr makai's Boss
earlier this year police reopened the
case and searched the Hertfordshire Farm
where the Hussein Brothers kept Mrs
Makai prisoner they found no trace of
her
I learned to live with it a long time
ago the loss of my mother and the way it
happened so I don't really want to go on
and on forever but if someone's willing
to have a quick look or a proper look
for us on this huge area
maybe that's a good idea
there's no evidence that any police have
ever searched here for Muriel Makai and
certainly her family were never told of
the solicitors letter nor it seems were
detectives on the case and today
Scotland Yard is reluctant to start a
new search
the officer now in charge of the case
has dismissed the claim as one single
strand of intelligence with the killer
and his solicitor dead he said he can't
validate the information
Martin brunt Sky News Essex
the Family itself has organized recently
some basic scanning of that Beach area
but it's a vast area and they've had to
give up
um they have heard from the police the
police clearly as you've seen in my
report do not believe that the
information justifies a new search but
the family continue to hope that they'll
change the minds of Scotland Yard
officers
Martin thank you
British Medical Association is warning
that the NHS is in danger of complete
collapse with senior medical
professionals planning to leave a poll
by the organization found that more than
two in five plan to leave the NHS in the
next year
with pay and pension tax Arrangements
some of the reasons they planned to
leave
the poll found that 44 percent of
Hospital Consultants plan to leave over
the next year amongst consultant
surgeons it's even higher half said they
plan to leave in the next year and 9 in
10 Consultants also said that the pay
rise they received this year was
inadequate and unacceptable
joining us now is the Deputy chair of
the British Medical Association
Consultants committee and that's Dr
shanu Data hello to you thank you very
much India for joining us on the program
this morning um talk to us in more
detail if you would please about this
survey
um and how seriously you think the
government might be taking it
good morning Kay uh this survey was
conducted in August it was a survey of 8
000 consultants in England and it will
make very uh depressing reading for
anyone who's interested in getting out
of Health Service back in shape as you
say
um the figures are really quite Stark
about half of Consultants said that the
um that they would wish to leave the NHS
or at least take a break in the next 12
months and that figure Rises to more
than half the Specialties like
consultants for a piggy Parton for
surgeons and anesthetists nine out of 10
said that the 4.5 pay award that the
government awarded last time was um
totally unacceptable or uh inadequate
and I think this reflects the state of
play in Consultants
um in terms of the low morale filling
undervalued and
um represents a very Stark reading
indeed okay talk to us about the pension
tax trap I know the question hinted at
that during his mini budget and I have
heard the Prime Minister talk about it
as well perhaps you could explain it to
us in more detail
so
um alongside pay and working conditions
uh pension Taxation and a tax trap is
another reason that a doctors senior
doctors are being um are taking the
decision to retire early or to cut cut
their hours
uh the government did announce some
sticking plasters as we could describe
it in recent months in terms of allowing
some doctors uh to be able to continue
to work
um and and claim what's called partial
retirement
um but that is simply not going far
enough and it won't stop The Exodus of
the most senior doctors what needs to
happen is that the
um the unfair uh taxation of Pensions uh
needs to be uh removed the way to do
that is to alter the legislation that
underlies uh pensions in the finance act
at the moment Consultants uh like other
people uh get tax relief for their
pensions and instead of that tax relief
what the BMA is saying is that
the pension taxation should be ruined
instead so that uh the real food would
no longer be a factor in that taxation
so what would that mean would that mean
that as a result we would see more
Consultants wanting to to work for
longer within the NHS
so the number of uh Consultants
who are cutting hours and leaving the
NHS has tripled in recent years the
average age of Consultants retiring is
approaching something like 59 those
changes would mean that Consultants
could stay on longer and work for as
long as they needed to or wanted to in
the NHS rather than being driven down
and driven out of the NHS in the current
way
excuse me
um have you had any contact at all from
the health secretary
we are we are in the process of
contacting the health secretary and we'd
like to meet her to talk about pay to
work pensions and we're also concerned
about the working conditions that have
got worse and worse
um in the NHS for for Consultants let's
remember the Consultants are the most
senior doctors in hospitals they tend to
the people who lead their clinical teams
they're responsible for teaching the
next Generations of doctors they lead on
Research redesigning their service and
innovating uh the Health Service so
these are uh people who the Health
Service can ill afford to lose
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
very much for joining us thank you
also still to come the winners of the
photographer of the Year award 2022 have
been announced following a series of
stunning submissions it's the 58th year
of the award and contenders will be
displayed at the Natural History Museum
uh this kind of I'm sure we can show you
this photo that was actually the winning
photograph
um it so you have to have a quick look a
close look I should say it depicts a
snow leopard there you go hunting can
you see him there he is bottom left hand
side about a third of the way up your
screen
it's a great picture isn't it well
joining us now is the man who took the
photo and the winner of the mammal
Behavior category in the wildlife
photographer of the Year 2022 Anand
nambia Hi how are you I'm doing good see
you thank you very much indeed for
joining us tell us about the photo so
this photo was taken uh in North India
uh in a place called spiti Valley
we were tracking the snow leopard uh
since morning and the Snow Leopard
spotted this group of ibex uh and and it
pretty successfully stocked uphill from
the Ibex and then it and end this photo
it's kind of chasing them down trying to
bring one of them down so did it catch
them no I didn't okay uh how did you
capture it so I was standing in in the
opposite Cliff face so this is happening
so there's there are two parallel Cliffs
so if this was happening on on the on on
The Cliff face opposite to me and I'm
standing on the other side very
difficult to see aren't they they are
very very difficult very very tough
terrain yeah uh high altitudes so you
had to train didn't you had to have a
fitness ratio yes I mean I'm I'm
generally a bit bulky so I had to kind
of train uh in the months leading up uh
to my uh trip to these to these areas
okay we all have our winter coat on
that's fine
um so
what is it particularly about snow
leopards that you wanted to capture on
film
so I so I I have I have a passion to
photograph nature and and in India you
have uh Tigers you have leopards you
have Asiatic lions
uh snow leopards has always been the the
Holy Grail in terms of photographing
cats and it's been my dream at least for
a few decades to see one right yeah and
and to have a moment like this happen in
front of you it's it's it's really
really simple the pictures actually
while we're talking to you obviously
they thought that this was the best
they're all going to be shown I think in
the Natural History Museum yes is that
right
um what makes what makes a good
photograph
so I would say that you need to
Captivate or engage a person looking at
the photograph
a good photograph would uh spark
curiosity
that's wonderful yeah symmetry is
awesome uh it sparked the Curiosity of
that person to learn a bit more about
that species or or that landscape and
hopefully that that curiosity would then
lead to empathy and and and and support
to kind of keep that intact okay I think
we've got a picture of a whale coming up
um as well uh tell us how you heard that
irwan and how you felt
so so they they disclosed the winners in
March but we were told to kind of keep
it uh strictly on the wraps wow yeah
this is the winning image so this is a
wonderful image
so yeah so it's been it's been six
months where well we had to kind of keep
it uh Secret
uh but yes I mean absolutely related to
know so what's next
well uh I'm I'm planning a few more
trips uh early next year uh so hopefully
some good images from there as well yeah
and that I'm guessing you'd like the
Symmetry on that one as well that's
wonderful and it's a beautiful
photograph isn't it beautiful what sort
of camera do you use so I use I use a
Nikon uh with a with a 500 mm so I have
a range of lens and cameras what did you
use for the one with the leopard so it's
a 500 mm a lens with a Nikon okay SLR
camera okay that's a great picture too
isn't it welcome home wonderful or not
go go somewhere else I think if the
birds were in your house um it's great
to see you and when are they up at the
Natural History Museum from Friday until
I'm not sure about that a long time a
long time and this is your image yes
that's absolutely superb thank you so
much thank you guys absolutely love that
picture my son's a big fan of snow
leopards I know that he'll very much
like it as much as I do thank you very
much indeed thanks a lot uh what does
Jacob Reese smog think about mortgages
on the increase how much is his find out
top of the year
[Music]